[Music]
there's quite a lot in silence in the
soul about the ethics of the way we
treat non-human animals I say non-human
because of course we are animals were
not plants were not fungi were not
bacteria we are we are animals there is
a double standard in our ethics at
present which place which builds a wall
around our own species Homo sapiens
which is rather an evolutionary or you
think about the fact that we are close
cousins of chimpanzees we think about
the fact that we are descended from a
common ancestor that lived only about 6
or 7 million years ago if you want to
erect a moral wall around our species
and say for example that a human embryo
even a very beginning human embryo long
before it develops a nervous system is
somehow worthy of more moral
consideration than an adult chimpanzee
then there is a rather an evolutionary
viewpoint if you look back in our
ancestry at what point would you draw
the line would you give if there were
Australopithecus our answers almost
certainly our ancestor Australopithecus
of 3 million years ago if you were to
meet what if one had survived in the
African jungle would you give it the
same moral consideration as as the rest
of us or would you say no no that's but
has the same moral consideration as a
chimpanzee if we look back in history a
couple of centuries ago most people
accepted slavery and nowadays of course
that's a horrifying thought no we don't
know civilized person today accepts
slavery and if you look back further
still we had the appalling things that
the Romans were doing in the Colosseum
with with spectator sport watching
people killing other people or lions
killing people regarding it as fun
entertainment to take the children out
to we're certainly getting better as
Steven Pinker has said in his book the
better angels of our nature and Michael
Shermer has in his book on the moral arc
so we're changing a lot and it's
therefore
sort of fairly obvious thing to do to
look into the future and say what will
our future descendants think when they
look back at us the way we look back at
our slave-owning ancestors with horror
what will our descendants look back on
it in our time and I think the obvious
candidate would be the way we treat
non-human animals my view would be that
we want to avoid suffering therefore the
criterion would be can this creature
suffer this is the criterion that Jeremy
Bentham the great moral philosopher laid
out can it can they suffer there's every
reason to think that mammals at least
and and probably many more can scan
suffer perhaps as much as we can pain
think about what pain is for
biologically speaking pain is a warning
to the animal don't do that again if the
animal does something which is which
results in pain that is a kind of ritual
death it's telling the animal if you do
that again you might die and you might
fail to reproduce that's why natural
selection has built pain into our
nervous system has built the capacity to
feel pain into our nervous systems so
don't mess around with a with Hornets
because it's painful don't do that again
don't pick up burning coals from the
fire don't do that again
there's absolutely no reason as far as I
can see why a nonhuman animal a dog or a
chimpanzee or a cow should be any less
capable of feeling pain than we can when
you think of what pain is actually doing
pain feels like something primitive
feels like something like seeing color
or smelling or a rose or something like
that it doesn't feel like the kind of
thing for which you need intellect and
actually you can go even further than
that you might say since pain is there
to warn the animal not to do that again
an animal which is a slow learner an
animal which is not particularly
intelligent might actually need more
intense
pain in order to deter it from doing
that again than a human who is
intelligent enough to learn quickly not
to do that again so it's it's even
possible that non-human animals are
capable of feeling more intense pain
than we are I'm not sure how far I want
to push that argument but I think at
least I could say there's absolutely no
reason to suppose that they feel less
pain than we do and we should give them
the benefit of the doubt
you